رغم انه يقضي حاليا حكما بالسجن مدى
الحياه لكنه لا يكف عن اثاره الرعب
والتسبب في ازهاق الارواح لدرجه ان
المكسيك تحولت الى ساحه حرب بسبب اعتقال
نجله
الجنسي مكسيكي التهمه تجاره المخدرات
والقتل
بامبراطور
المخدراتين كان عنيفا وعديم الرحمه ولا
يهاب الموت جزاء من يتباطئ في العمل معه
طلقه في الراس لم يتردد في تعذيب وقتل
منافسه ففي احدى المرات امر رجاله بحفر
قبر لرجل كان محتجزا لديه ثم القاه فيه
ودفنه حيه
في عائله الفقيره طرد من المنزل قبل ان
يبلغ 15 عاما فبدا بالزراعه الماريجوانا
وذاع صيته في منطقه ليلقبه بالتشابه او
القصير هذا القصير تحول مع مرور السنوات
اذا احد العمالقه في تجاره المخدرات وضع
على قوائم المطلوبين وطرد للسنوات
عام
1993 لكنه استطاع الهربه في عام 2001
مختلئا الى سله غسيل عامله الشامبو على
تطوير عمله وكثف عمليات التهريب للولايات
المتحده لتصنفه ادارته مكافحه المخدرات
الامريكيه على انه اكبر مهربين مخدرات في
كل العصور وفي عمليه شاركت بها دول عده
اعيد اعتقاله في المكسيك عام 2014 رفضت
سلطات بلاده تسليمه للبنايات المتحده
واصرت على انه لن يهرب كما في المره
السابقه ولكن ذلك لم يحصل فقط فر القصيره
من السجن ثانيه وهذه المره عبر نفق طويل
[موسيقى]
علينا ان نوضح امرا واحدا سوف نلاحق كل
متورط في القضيه سنلاحق كل من خان
المؤسسات والمجتمع
لم تدمر
طويلا فما هي الا سته اشهر حتى اعيده
اعتقاله
[موسيقى]
ولاحقا قبيله السلطات المكسيكيه بتسليمه
للولايات المتحده وبالتزامن مع ذلك قتلت
عصابته القاضي الذي تراس قضيه التسليم في
عام 2019 حكمت محكمه امريكيه على التابو
بالسجن مدى الحياه بالعديد من التهم
ابرزها تجاره المخدرات وغسيل الاموال
[موسيقى]
يعتقد ان لالكابه احد عشر ابنا وابنه على
الاقل لا يعرف منهم على نطاق واسع سوى
ابنه اوفيده المعروف باسمي
او الفار الذي تسلم زعامه عصابه سنانوه
خلفا لوالده الا ان السلطات المكسيكيه لم
تهدا حتى اعتقالته هو الاخر ففي عام 2019
قبضت قوه من الجيش على ارتون في مدينه
كوريا كام العصابه لينتشر رجاله في
المدينه ويعيث فيها فساده اغلقوا ميادينها
سيطروا على المباني الحكوميه اغلق المطار
ودهم سجن المدينه واطلقوا صراحه عشرات
المسجونين وهدد بالمزيد اذا لم يطلق
وفي النهايه خضعت الحكومه واطلت صراحه
خسرت جوله ولكنها لم ترمي المنديل ففي يوم
الخميس من يناير عام 2023 اعادت اعتقاله
فاندلعت موجه جديده اسفرت عن مقتل 29 شخصا
بينهما 10 جنود ومع كل هذه الارقام
المرعبه لم يتضح بعد ما اذا كان سيتم
تسليم ايرتون للولايات المتحده مثل والده
الشامبو